Today we'll be speaking with Dr. Roy Baumeister on self regulation and emotion.
Dr Baumeister is currently a professor of psychology at Florida State
University.
He received his phd in social psychology from Princeton in 1978 and did a
postdoctoral fellowship in sociology at UC Berkeley.
Dr Baumeister's research spans multiple topics including self and identity,
self regulation,
interpersonal rejection,
and the need to belong,
sexuality and gender aggression,
self esteem meaning and self presentation.
He is received research grants from the National Institutes of health and from
the Templeton Foundation.
He has authored over 500 publications and his 31 books include evil inside human
violence and cruelty,
the cultural animal meanings of life and the New York Times bestseller
willpower,
rediscovering the greatest human strength,
the Institute for Scientific Information Lists Dr Baumeister among the handful
of the most cited an influential psychologist in the world.
He has received lifetime achievement awards from the Society for personality and
social psychology from the international society for self and identity.
And most recently the William James Award from the association for Psychological
Science.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Dr. Roy Baumeister on
self regulation and emotion.
So welcome.
Right.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thank you for having me,
Jim.
Great.
What I wanted to start at is asking you just a little bit about what you know,
got you.
First interested in the idea of emotion or studying emotion.
It's hard to say.
I mean,
I'm interested in everything.
My project is,
I want to understand what human life is all about and so emotion is a big part
of it.
Uh,
I got to it a little bit slower than some of the others.
I think some of the specific ideas came from findings that surprised me.
I always assumed as I think most people in our field do that emotion is
immediately causes behavior.
When we review papers or whenever we submit them and and so on,
the alternate explanations and that's how scientists work.
And I was,
how can we explain this action?
It's usually because the person felt this way or had this emotion or we were
afraid or they were angry or they were upset or they were happy or something.
So emotion is assumed to be the driving force.
Uh,
and yet several big investigations of mine and to other phenomena they have just
didn't turn out to be true.
Well,
one of the first was,
uh,
it was self destructive behavior or something.
I'm interested in because that's a paradox.
And why do people do think that it's crew themselves up?
Uh,
and yet,
uh,
you know,
the assumption,
well,
they felt guilty so they want it to be punished or something like that.
But no,
that doesn't appear to be to emotion is relevant,
but it,
uh,
it's not,
you know,
because of some direct influence of emotional state.
And then I work on rejection there.
We assumed too,
um,
that,
uh,
people who were rejected or excluded by others,
they'd be upset and that would drive their behavior.
We started doing the studies and the lab,
we got huge behavioral effects all the time and yet we couldn't find any sign of
emotion.
So,
obviously emotion was not driving it and that,
that led me to start questioning,
uh,
how much of a role does emotion play in guiding behavior?
Uh,
so I think that was one of the big,
big things that got me interested in it.
So what I want to ask you then,
I mean,
since you've gotten interested in it,
you've done some really interesting studies that shed a lot of important
insights on emotion and the nature of self regulation.
So for example,
I mean you're widely known,
you know,
for your influential work on the role of human self regulation in particular for
this concept of ego depletion.
And I wondered if you could just tell us a bit more about what you see as the
central findings or discoveries in this line of work.
Uh,
defining there is that,
do you know after people exert self control after the controlled regulate their
behavior in,
uh,
in,
in one task,
if we present them with another,
they do worse on that.
So it looks like some of their energy or willpower or something is used up in
the first act of self control.
So they don't have as much available.
Uh,
for the second one,
controlling emotion can be one of those tasks.
Uh,
uh,
so,
after say you've a had a hard day at work or after you've been making yourself
concentrate or controlling your performance to make yourself persevere or
whatever,
uh,
then you might have less,
less will power for controlling your,
uh,
your emotions afterwards,
then you might react more strong.
You know,
you might let your emotions guide your behavior in some way.
And more recent findings are suggesting that a one effect of this depleted state
is that people actually feel their emotions more intensely.
Hmm.
Uh,
so not only are you not restraining them,
although that,
you know,
that might somehow feed into it,
uh,
but,
you know,
their mount you're upset by watching and upsetting movie is higher if you're,
your willpower has been depleted in state of ego depletion.
Um,
that's great.
I wanted to ask you a little bit more about some of the work that you've done
that is more directly relevant to motion as well.
So you've proposed a really interesting theory of emotion as this feedback
system,
right?
That typically has more indirect influences on behavior as opposed to more
directly causing,
you know,
human behavior.
And I wondered if you could elaborate on this approach as to how you think
emotion shapes behavior.
Okay.
Um,
we,
uh,
I like everyone else started out with the assumption that a usually emotion is
what causes behavior.
It's your current emotional state.
And that sort of means that the beginnings of behavior are somehow in the
emotion both state.
And that's been criticized by other people who were starting to say there are a
lot of behaviors and not that many emotions.
That is something that has many different emotions.
So how you act has to be somehow worked out in the situation.
There might be emotions have a sort of broad approach or avoid tendencies cause
those are basic.
And then you figured out how to apply that in the immediate situation.
But to say that,
uh,
you know,
anger contains the beginning of aggression in it.
Uh,
guilt contains whatever,
you know,
they're all sorts of behaviors people do because they feel guilty.
Yeah.
Uh,
that's hot.
That's,
that's question about,
um,
the most common example in the one everybody uses and I think that fooled us is,
is that fear makes you run away.
Uh,
but increasingly people are saying that fear is not a good model for other
emotions.
A lot of researchers say that,
well in nature,
there isn't time for the animal to get afraid.
Uh,
it has to take off immediately as soon as there's the threatening stimulus.
If you wait for an emotional state to build up and then for the brain to say,
okay,
I'm afraid that's it.
So I better get moving by then the Predator will,
it will have eaten you.
So,
uh,
if the flight happens before the fear looking at this and we have you reviewed a
massive amount of information,
uh,
suggesting that yes,
indeed.
Uh,
emotion is not usually a,
the behavior and the way it is.
It's not that adaptive of behavior.
People Act because of their emotional states.
They tend to do things that they're sorry about it.
It's like the familiar example.
Don't send an email message when you're still mad.
Calm down
before you hit them.
You can write it but don't hit send.
Uh,
and,
and that's it.
It's,
it interferes with your judgment.
So what that means is that that's not why we evolved emotions just to guide our
behavior.
If it makes us do things that are often stupid and self destructive,
still people without emotions don't hate very effectively.
There's something useful there.
So there has to be some other process.
And that made us think it's a,
what emotion does is make you reflect on the experience after the fact so that
you learn the lesson,
uh,
and that you,
you extract how to behave in the future that turns out to be highly adaptive and
is pretty common.
It hasn't been studied nearly as much,
uh,
but we think,
maybe the next couple of decades.
So,
um,
emotion researchers should stop looking so much at current emotional state and
started looking at anticipated emotional states.
The guilt is a great example in that it's a much better example than,
than fear.
Perhaps as a prototype for how emotion works in general.
You do something,
it turns out to be bad and you feel guilty.
I mean,
it must,
people don't deliberately do things that are,
are going to make them feel guilty.
Uh,
they do something and then I'll just say,
oh,
you heard Mary or you made me feel bad.
I have this.
And then you feel guilty and you feel bad.
Guilt makes you reflect on what you did.
Uh,
I shouldn't have done this.
Or if I had done this,
it would work out better.
And so then,
and then it stores a little trace,
a little like emotional tank so that the next time you're in that situation,
uh,
you're tempted to do the same thing.
And you have this little memories of this little tag,
which it has an automatic,
a bit of effect attached to it and says,
oh,
that's danger.
And that reminds you of the last time you did that you got in trouble and you
felt bad.
So you avoided.
It can really be a powerful and effective guide of in behavior if you almost
never feel guilty.
Uh,
as long as you avoid doing things that you will make you feel guilty,
uh,
then you can stay out of trouble.
And that's,
that's really the deal.
That's what we strive for in civilized life.
You know,
it's not too to feel guilty all the time for the bad things we do,
but rather to learn to avoid doing things that will make us feel guilty.
And if everybody did that would be a better place.
So it's interesting cause you've talked about the role of anticipation and
reflection in your model and I wonder if you could just elaborate a tiny bit
more.
I know you've alluded to this on the role of feedback,
right?
And,
and the way emotion shapes behavior.
Yes.
Uh,
uh,
um,
remember emotion,
we're talking here about the full fledge conscious emotion that takes a little
while to arise in the heat of the moment in the crisis or whatever that might
be,
um,
might get in the way.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there seems to be a delayed reaction that afterwards you feel bad or you feel
good about something that pulls your mind tobacco back in to reflect on what you
did so that you are going to extract the lesson.
Um,
it's especially important for humans because our social lives are so
complicated.
There's so many things going on that,
uh,
you know,
we can reflect on what we did badly and learn all the different ways,
uh,
that we might avoid it.
I mean,
you go into a store to buy something and you,
you,
uh,
something goes wrong and you buy a badly and you feel bad afterwards.
Well,
you can't never buy anything again.
You can to avoid wearing clothes or whatever.
So you figure how in that situation could I have avoided the problem or the bad
outcome?
It takes really some scrutiny over or ruminating,
mulling over and emotion seems to be really good at that.
We know emotions stimulates you to replay events,
not just how they happened,
but in called counterfactual a ways.
You replay the event with different actions and different outcomes and find that
you settle on one will,
this then would have produced a good outcome.
This is maybe what I should have done.
And then you store that away and the next time a similar situation arises,
there's a little,
uh,
a tag and a little bit of a,
a little bit of the,
uh,
automatic to effect the feeling and brings back,
yes,
I learned my lesson the last time and you behave better.
So it's a,
again,
it's not that the current emotional state is teaching you how to act in the
present,
but it's helping you learn the lesson from what happened so that the next time,
uh,
you can do better.
And as I said,
as you learned to anticipate the emotions,
that really facilitates the process to a,
as with guilt,
if you learn off,
like do this again,
I'll end up feeling guilty again so I'm not going to do this.
Great.
So thank you for sharing your insights on this really important work in terms of
how emotion shapes behavior and also kind of the role of self regulation.
Um,
I wondered if you could say a little bit,
as you're thinking forward,
where are you see,
you know,
the,
the future of the field headed in this domain?
All right.
Uh,
well,
I,
uh,
wow,
sure.
The boss,
um,
in our theory about emotion has feedback.
There's the currently felt emotion,
your,
your current state.
And that's what researchers study a lot of.
And then there's the anticipation of how you could feel,
uh,
in the future.
Um,
now when we looked at which of those are driving behavior,
we found the current emotional state.
And,
and we,
we,
we took this,
we looked in our top journal,
the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology,
uh,
every article since 1987 when they started doing mediation analysis.
Uh,
and we found several hundred articles that tested for mediation by emotion.
And the vast majority were not significant emotion.
You're currently felt emotional state was not driving your behavior.
Uh,
we also looked at once on an dissipated emotion.
And,
uh,
there we're only about a dozen,
but 90% of those,
uh,
guided behavior.
So it looks like if we want to understand how people act,
uh,
looking at anticipated emotion is the way to go,
but nobody's doing it yet.
So I think the field is likely to wake up sometime in the next 10 years.
Uh,
maybe some of us encouraging them to say that trying to understand behavior
based on what's driving it in your current emotional state.
That's not getting us this far.
But looking at anticipated emotion,
we haven't looked at that and that's where all the action is that really
deserves a lot more,
uh,
intensive study.
Um,
I think,
uh,
we need to sharpen up our terms and our concepts and our understanding of the
term emotion is used in lots of different ways.
Uh,
we had a distinguished sort of those little tags.
You get a little twinge of a,
this is good or this is bad,
that that counts as emotion,
uh,
to some people.
But it's very different from what,
you know,
walking around and weeping and sobbing with the remorse or greed for something
because something really bad just happened.
So separating those states,
I think a,
those are important.
And understanding how they fit together,
how emotion fits in the big picture.
I think that's still a challenge.
This emotion,
cognition,
motivation,
uh,
those seem to be the three big categories,
with behavior being,
being eloquent and so,
exactly how does the emotion fit in there and contribute,
uh,
to,
occasionally messing us up.
But more often than not helping us live the good life.
I think that's the way to go.
Thank you.
And my last question for you is,
what advice do you have for students who are thinking about embarking in this
field?
What might you tell them?
No,
just study emotion.
Um,
I think the most pressing need is far a methodological creativity.
If you can think of ways,
uh,
to study emotional stage to get people in them.
That's what's held it back.
We know a lot more about cognition than about emotion.
And I think that's not cause cognition is more important,
uh,
are more prevalent.
It's just that it's easier to study.
So,
uh,
always be on the lookout for new methods of that I think historically has held
back the study of emotion.
Um,
so,
uh,
come up with new methods and then,
be really disciplined in critical,
and I'm looking at the ideas,
uh,
theories and to try to understand what's right about everyone and what's wrong
about it.
Great.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking today.
Oh,
thank you for having me on.
So this concludes our experts and emotion interview with Dr. Roy Baumeister from
Florida State University.
Thank you so much again.